[Music]
i switched my profile to devops recently
but i was lacking in that knowledge for
this new rule
simplyland's post-graduate course in
devops in collaboration with celtx ctmo
is helping me tremendously to understand
things better
and also take new assignments in my new
room thank you so much
hi i am milan parker i live in the
silicon valley and i have more than 20
plus years of experience in iit industry
in various worlds in my previous role i
was traveling a lot meeting up with
different customers
and delivering infrastructure solutions
to them
and i did that for almost 14 years
but i needed a break from traveling job
and i decided to transition into
in-house engineering jobs
i was excited to join one of the leading
and fastest growing cyber security firm
in the bay area as a principal devops
engineer as i started working there i
got exposed to various devops tools
although i had infrastructure domain
expertise
there's so much to learn and grasp in
the devops world and i needed some help
so when i started researching online
this simply learns postgraduate course
in devops in collaboration with caltech
city and caught my attention
caltech is a well reputed institution
the curriculum was well structured well
designed and it offered exactly what i
was looking for
it turned out to be one of the best
decisions to pursue this course my
devops fundamentals are strong and my
linkedin profile is capturing a lot of
attention amongst the recruiters
also i'm taking up
new important assignments in my role
at my company because now i know
docker and kubernetes the course was
online and all the instructor-led
sessions and the labs were over the
weekends lasted for almost four hours
the instructors were knowledgeable and
were from industry backgrounds and that
made sessions very interesting they also
shared all their experiences
this is a great online platform for it
professionals
i think learning should never stop and
one must simply learn
[Music]